every friday during women's history
month
we're looking at how the pandemic is
affecting women and work
this week we're focusing on the more
than 96 sorry
67 million women who are currently
employed in the u.s
according to linkedin 70 of working
women
feel they need to lower their career
expectations
and rethink the progress they once
thought possible
charisma jay has fought hard just to
keep her brooklyn new york dance studio
open in the pandemic she pivoted to
online classes
and cut her staff's pay
[Music]
when i wanted to open this establishment
i wanted it to be a safe space
where we could help people access their
biggest dreams
we would sell out and we were putting on
shows at king's theater
off broadway when the coronavirus shut
down new york city last march
charisma j's dance studio lost more than
half its business
you know stat pivots that pivot we've
always known that name of that step
this pandemic has made me pivot in ways
that no jazz dance class could teach
so she turned to teaching classes on
zoom
good morning we managed to flip on a
dime and go virtual
as an institution when so many other
dance studios were not
while the studio was empty for three
months
rent was still due so jay had to make a
difficult decision
i had to ask our teachers if they would
be okay with taking a pay cut
like and it was significant by at least
15 20
it's heartbreaking i let myself cry so i
was feeling like
we're not going to be able to sustain as
a non-profit in this for-profit world i
said to our adult
clients we're going to close the parents
didn't let me but the majority of them
basically committed to paying tuition
despite community support jay's classes
are not back to pre-pandemic class sizes
and she's now two months behind on the
studio's rent
it's just grace and mercy at this point
that when i put the key in the door it
still turns that door open you know
when i turn the lights on they come on
actually and
i can definitely attest that to the
community
yeah so many people surviving on grace
and mercy right now first on cbs this
morning
linkedin is revealing new data about how
the pandemic is affecting women in the
workforce
as part of their conversations for
change series
caroline fairchild is editor at large of
linkedin's global news team she joins us
caroline welcome thanks for being here
good morning
good morning as we heard charisma jay
saying so many women have had to pivot
uh
during this pandemic how can employers
help working women right now what can
they do
so the pandemic has exacerbated tensions
and biases that working women felt
well before this crisis what we're
seeing through this survey of working
women is that
60 of women are feeling like they have
to downplay their career aspects right
now
in terms of what employers can do we
need to make remote work right now
work for working women so many women
right now were thrown into remote work
in march when this pandemic began and
it's just not working there's no
sustainable policies in place and
it has to it can be small things
managers can just say look here are the
working hours where we expect you to
answer to emails
don't be one of those managers who's
sending emails to your employees at 1 am
small things like that can go a long way
and i think what we have to stress here
anthony is that this isn't about fixing
women it's about fixing companies
fixing workplaces that don't work for
women one third of women apparently say
they are not feeling supported by their
companies at this point what kinds of
conversations should be happening
right what that really tells us is that
despite the struggles that women are
facing at home there's still this stigma
the stigma that you can't feel like you
can talk about with your manager
what you're facing at home and the
pandemic has made all of that worse and
that's honestly why we launched
conversations for change
we want to make sure that these
conversations are happening that
employers are talking with their
managers
survey data shows us it's just simply
talking about the challenges that you're
facing at work with your manager
can go a long way for you to feel
supported and make women feel like they
don't have to be less ambitious with
their careers
you know a lot of women have taken a pay
cut carolyn or they've reduced their
hours just to keep their jobs
what advice do you have for them that's
one and number two
what role should or can men play in this
if you could answer both of those
absolutely gail i'm glad you brought
that up so many women had to take a pay
cut because of this pandemic and we know
prior to the pandemic women were less
likely than their male counterparts to
ask for a raise
i think we're at a point in the economic
recovery where it won't seem tone deaf
if your employer is doing well to start
to ask for a raise so come
to your employer with a case a case for
how you added extra responsibilities
during this pandemic a case for how
you're exceeding expectations in your
role
and in terms of men they have to get a
seat at the table
it can't just be you and me having these
conversations anthony needs to be in
these conversations
everyone needs to have conversations
together so that we ensure that everyone
feels like they're being supported at
work
just men simply talking about the fact
that they have challenges at home as
well is a boon for working women
all right caroline fairchild yeah very
good points thank you so much for being
with us this morning
around 275 000 women left the workforce
in january compared to 71 thousand men
next week will focus on women who felt
they've been forced
to leave their jobs during the pandemic